[Applause]
that kind of shooting makes me want to
do the robot
[Music]
dance that's what happens when you hit
the bottle pal you go to sleep in duk Sp
you wake up in pukes Berry pukes Berry
hey what do you do
no the worst has happened I'm covered in
human
fees that's a good look for you but for
health reasons I should probably spray
you
off
[Music]
smell you later
[Laughter]
poopsicle you're
freaking I know I
[Music]
am little help
please your Tong
tickle tile good luck Whitey you're
going to need
it okay let's give the little guy some
support
ah jesz I'm Crow did I just see two
Persian cats on your ass I think I'm
going to
your horn wordss try to
lights
okay
one two good to see you still got those
circus feet men's 11 right foot
children's nine left foot at your
service yeah now I assume you've done
your pregame stretching no let me do it
right Now 1 2 3 4 5 6 okay that's good
but don't forget your hammies of course
Whitey wouldn't understand what getting
flipped off means he's so behind the
times he thinks Viagra is a big
waterfall oh boy does that mean we're
[Music]
skined I don't see any skin monkey man
just pass me the ball all right fuzzy
wuzzy all right see it down way don't
travel don't double dribble I want a
good clean game and no back talk hey
orangutang you're playing not reing he's
right look for your opening and take
[Music]
it there it
is now set yourself and
Sh oh
no are you finally dead old man
I'll be over to feed the cats in the
morning Mrs
[Music]
Addison